dea
今から日本語の講座を行います
もうちょっとしたら新学期が始まるということで今日は学校そして大学に関係する日本
語を紹介したいと思う
ちなみにそう風邪ひいている60ドルもする
銀器の教科書まあもしくは日本語の教科書いくらでも無料で
貸してもらえる公立図書館1年間3000ドルもする外国人でいっぱいの大学の
日本語講座
あなたが既に持っている実在する日本語がいつでも聞ける字幕機能も付いている
ネットフィックス鬼め
アニメ以外のもの文法さえ正しければ良しとする学校の先生
スマホさえあればいつでもどこでもできる発音の録音分析極めて重要なのに話す能力
一切見ない
日本語能力試験必ず話す能力を見る
モスバーガーリュックもしくはカバン
毎回毎回中ドラムとる
文法の家庭教師短編小説でも無料で添削してもらえる
ランゲート日本で英語を教えるという夢
日本の会社例えばモスバーガーで働くという夢ノート death note
anime club 例えば日本語倶楽部
宿題でしか漢字を書く機会が無い時代に先生が毎日宿題として出す感じの練習用紙
学校の教育課程よりずっと早く上達できるはに彼にマクドナルド
フレッシュネスバーガー会話相手であるアメリカ人の同級生スカイプ用を
学校に戻らないことん
me